- [Instructor] When we humans look
at the universe around us,
we're blown away by the complexity
and the diversity of
all the things we see,
from the scale of things
in the cosmos like stars.
This is a picture of our sun,
all the way down to a more human scale,
and all the way down to
the microscopic scale.
This is a visualization of a coronavirus.
It seems like there's an infinite number
of things out there.
But an interesting
question has always been,
are there some basic building blocks,
things, a smaller set,
a finite set of things
that we can put together to
make up all of this complexity?
Ancients thought about,
maybe it's fire, water, wind,
but now we know that there
are things called elements,
and we have classified them
on the periodic table of elements.
And we know today of about 118 elements,
but we might discover more.
But what's mind blowing is all matter
that we know of in the universe is made up
of combinations of these elements.
Now, what's even more amazing is most
of what we experience in our
everyday lives is made up
of an even smaller
subset of these elements.
For example, almost 99% of the mass
on Earth is made up of
these eight elements.
And if we look at ourselves,
if you were to stare at your
hand or look in the mirror,
life, as we know it,
is made up of mainly these six elements:
hydrogen, carbon, nitrogen,
oxygen, phosphorus, and sulfur.
Now, the earth and life is
made up of other elements,
but it is amazing how much complexity
and how much can be made with combinations
of the things that we see in
the periodic table of elements.
Now, the next question is, all right,
we can make things out of these elements,
but what if we were to
keep cutting an element
or what if we were to keep
cutting a substance down?
What is the smallest
unit that still maintains
the properties of an element?
And that unit, you have
probably heard the word,
is known as an atom,
and atoms can be further broken down.
In fact, an atom has a nucleus
and inside that nucleus,
it has subatomic
particles known as protons
and neutrons in that nucleus.
And then you could imagine buzzing around,
and we're talking about
very, very small scale,
and it's hard to pinpoint.
It's more of a probability
where you might find these,
but buzzing around that
nucleus, you have electrons,
and the protons have a positive charge,
the neutrons have a neutral charge,
and the electrons have a negative charge.
But everything we're
talking about is made up
of combinations of these
three fundamental particles,
and what's especially cool is
a given atom is mostly free space.
You have the dense nucleus
but then these atoms
are just buzzing around
when mostly free space.
And what actually gives
an atom the properties
of a specific element is the number
of protons we're dealing with.
So for example,
what makes an atom a hydrogen
is it has one proton.
What makes an atom a chlorine
is that it has 17 protons.
The number of electrons can change.
That will change its charge
and that might change how it
interacts with other atoms,
but it still will be classified
as a, for example, carbon,
regardless of how many electrons it has.
And similarly, the number
of neutrons don't affect its charge,
but it will affect the mass
that we're dealing with.
But even if you change
the number of neutrons
and you have the same number of protons,
you're still dealing,
if you say you have six protons,
no matter how many neutrons
or electrons you have,
you're still dealing with carbon.
And it's really interesting to appreciate
just how small atoms are.
If you think about it just as a number,
the width of, let's say, a carbon atom,
and there are smaller atoms,
like a hydrogen atom or a helium atom,
but the width of a carbon
atom is roughly one times 10
to the negative 10th meters.
Another way to think about it
and it depends on the context
you're seeing the carbon,
but roughly speaking, if
you took 10-billion carbons
and put them side by side, it
would be about a meter wide.
Or if you wanna blow
your mind even further,
if you had about 10-million carbons
and put them side by side, that
would be about a millimeter.
So try to approximate a millimeter.
A millimeter, depending on
the resolution of your screen,
might be something like that.
There would be 10-million carbons,
depending on how big you're
looking at this video,
just in that space over there.
If that doesn't blow your mind enough,
another way to think
about it is it's estimated
that there are more
atoms in a grain of sand
than there are grains of sand
in all of the beaches on Earth.
And if that doesn't blow your mind,
roughly speaking, if you took an apple
and if you made the apple
the size of the earth,
then an atom in that apple
would be the size of an apple.
You can hear that again and process that.
If you took, or another
way to think about it,
an atom of an apple is to the apple
as an apple is to all of Earth.
So atoms are tiny, tiny, tiny.
So I'm gonna leave you there.
That's enough mind blowing for one video.
And then in future videos,
we'll discuss more in depth
about atoms and the subatomic
particles that make them up,
and we'll talk more
about classifying the
different types of matter.